yesterday we had news of Tucker Carlson
abruptly leaving Fox News and we now
know that he was as seemed kind of
obvious yesterday but it wasn't
confirmed he was fired the the reasons
are still murky
um reports in the LA Times and other
places suggests that Rupert Rupert
Murdoch made the decision to get rid of
Tucker some in the media are suggesting
has to do with with uh you know
different lawsuits a discrimination
lawsuit that was filed by a former
Tucker producer
but I find that hard to believe given
that well Fox itself says that that
particular lawsuit has no merit and uh
which we would expect him to say
um and just based on the details that
have been reported it certainly seems
from from my perspective to having no
merit I mean this woman complains for
example uh about a jokey picture of
Nancy Pelosi that was hanging on a wall
in a law in a in an office somewhere
that's the kind of thing she's offended
by and filing a lawsuit about so I don't
think that's the reason I think that
there may have been many things that
that uh contributed to it but I think
that basically they pushed Tucker out
because of what he stands for what he
says
that's really what it comes down to
Tucker is not not a neocon corporatist
milk toast Republican
because he's not that he's not welcome
on Fox
they were looking for a reason to get
rid of him for that reason alone uh I
really think it's that simple Tucker is
also interesting and uh they seem to
have a problem with interesting people I
mean that goes all the way back to when
they fired Glenn Beck who committed the
crime of being interesting
there's something else to be said about
Tucker too um
which is that he's not only a great
talent
and he is a great talent like I said
yesterday his monologues make news
um he does monologues on the news and he
makes news with them this is a rare
Talent nobody else at Fox
is doing that nobody else in cable news
has that kind of talent it's as I said a
rare town
but aside from the talent Tucker's also
a uh he's also a good guy so just one
and as people are sharing different
stories about their encounters with tuck
Carlson so here's here's one quick
personal story and I think it tells
tells you a lot about him so years ago
this is maybe
um
I don't know so maybe four years ago
maybe five years ago
Tucker texted me one day out of the blue
um to tell me that he appreciates my
work and he you know he's encouraging me
to to keep going
now keep in mind I had a much smaller
profile back then this was when I
believe I was still doing my podcast out
of my car and there was about 30 people
who were you know watching it so
relatively obscure especially compared
to now
I didn't think the Tucker even knew who
I was and yet he took the time to track
down my phone number and send me a text
even though I obviously had nothing I
could give him in return it's not like
he needed me to uh promote you know his
work or something like that uh it was
just something that he felt compelled to
do and he did that is I I cannot stress
enough how rare that sort of thing is
probably in any business but especially
in this business
people will be nice to you
you know people will be nice to you but
it's because because they they usually
because they want something from you
they're being nice to you because they
want and oftentimes they want you to
promote something they want you to they
want you to put them in touch with
someone who you know it's like that sort
of thing so it's very transactional very
mercenary uh it's extremely rare that
somebody would just kind of reach out to
encourage you when you have nothing that
you can give them in return
and uh so that alone
I think tells you a lot about them uh
and the question now is what he does
next personally I think the daily wire
is the best place for him I'm a little
bit biased but I do I do really believe
that
you know I think if you're Tucker
Carlson you've got
you know basically
two two options or I guess there's a
third you could just decide you want to
get out of the Rat Race completely I
hope he doesn't do that
um but aside from that you can go off
and do your own thing
uh or you can join another institution
and uh I think that you know there are
other there are other institutions in
conservative media that do great work
but I don't think there's any other
place like daily wire so that would be
my pitch to him but we'll see what he
does uh of course there was a lot of
celebrating over this
um on the left as you can imagine
probably don't need any examples of that
but here's just one example from The
View as they first learned the news the
tuck Carlson had been fired and uh
here's how they reacted to that
word has just come down that Fox news
media and Tucker Carlson have agreed to
part ways
[Applause]
wave
you know we'll talk more about it
tomorrow because but we wanted to make
sure that we let you know what was going
well can I can I ask the audience if
they'll help me do something
come on folks
[Applause]
I
don't think anyone likes to celebrate
the demise of someone
well we don't want to celebrate the
demise of someone's career but we're
going to
uh but it's unfortunately it's actually
not the demise of Tucker Carlson's
career at all I think this is going to
work out better for him in the end to be
out from under Fox News and uh go to a
place where
um there's no one trying to control what
he says and whether that's out on his
own or somewhere else so it's certainly
not the demise of his career you have to
understand too that that
so much of this the reaction to Tucker
Carlson especially from other members of
the media is driven by pure jealousy
Megan Kelly I think made this point
yesterday and it's it's true especially
in reaction to this uh clip by The View
like lots of people immediate obviously
they hate him on ideological grounds uh
he is one of the most effective
advocates for
true conservative principles in Media
and so they hate him for that
but they hate them all the more because
he gets ratings
and
um and he can go on his own and host his
own show and carry a show by himself and
millions of people will tune in to watch
it and they'll talk about it
so that alone is enough reason for
especially the the hens on The View to
hate him
because they're all a bunch of you know
they're all a bunch of Sidekicks they
they could never take any one of those
women individually and many of them have
attempted to host their own shows and
they're all failures they it would it
could never you could never take one of
those women and put them on their own
show and expect millions of people to
tune in to listen what they have to say
it will never happen
so the fact that Tucker Carlson can be
compelling on his own commanding
presence sitting in front of a camera
and they could never do that
reason enough for them to hate him the
first step in growing up and being a
real man is getting off your parents
phone plan okay getting your own cell
phone plan gives you a sense of
Independence and responsibility and if
you're adult you just you need to be
paying for your own damn phone it's a
step towards becoming more
self-sufficient by paying for your own
finances you'll learn how to budget and
manage your money there are a ton of
cell phone cell phone providers out
there unfortunately most of them want to
lock you into horrific contracts and
will tack on hidden fees any chance they
get that's why I'm a huge fan of pure
talk there are no contracts no hassle
you can cancel at any time Pure Talk is
a plan that uses the same Nationwide
networks as major carriers to get the
same reliable coverage that you're used
to just without all the other junk they
offer a range of cell phone plans that
best fit your needs and your budget you
can get unlimited talk text and plenty
of data for just 30 bucks a month
switching over to Pure Talk is so easy
you can make the switch keep yourself um
keep your phone number with their U.S
customer service team you can make the
switch in as little as 10 minutes Pure
Talk is so sure that you're going to
love your service they're backing it up
in the a 100 money back guarantee so go
to puretalk.com enter promo code Walsh
just say 50 off your first month that's
puretalk.com promo code Walsh Pure Talk
is simply smarter Wireless
your online data includes personal
information such as your name address
phone number email address financial
information and login credentials
hackers want to steal this information
and sell it on the dark web where it can
be used for various criminal activities
such as phishing ransomware and identity
theft needless to say it's incredibly
important that you use a VPN to prevent
that from happening but choosing a VPN
you trust is equally as important that's
why we recommend using expressvpn every
time you go online expressvpn makes you
anonymous online by camouflaging your IP
address and replacing it with a
different secure IP of your choice
expressvpn also encrypts all of your
data so that it's protected from hackers
and anyone else that tries to tries to
spy on you I love expressvpn because it
doesn't log your activity lots of cheap
or free vpns they make money by selling
your data advertisers but expressvpn
doesn't do that they've even developed a
technology that makes their VPN servers
incapable of storing any data at all
expressvpn is incredibly easy to use
just fire up the app and click one
button plus it works on all of your
devices phone laptop even your Wi-Fi
router so if you like me and you believe
your internet data belongs to you then
expressvpn is the answer visit
expressvpn.com Walsh and get three extra
months free that's exp
resvpn.com Welsh expressvpn.com Walsh to
learn more
but there was other news in Cable in
cable news yesterday uh going from a guy
who didn't deserve to be fired because
he was the dominant figure and he's
getting in cable news and getting all
the ratings so that's Tucker Carlson
then we go over to a guy who certainly
did deserve to be fired he's been
deserving it for like 15 years Don Lemon
was uh was terminated and it was pretty
devastating to me because I found out
like right after we finished filming
yesterday that Don Lemon was fired
um which just meant that I I didn't have
a chance on the air
um to make fun of him for it but you
know at least now we can so CNN uh
decided to get rid of him uh he was not
happy about it he put out a statement
bashing the network which they then
responded to and it seems like the two
parties don't like each other that's my
that's my expert media analysis of the
of this situation as to what led to it
um there are many people who are
speculating that that uh this awkward
exchange which will play a little bit
for you between Don Lemon and Vivek
ramaswamy on Friday may have been the
final straws obviously was not the thing
that on its own determined that he was
going to be fired but this is kind of
the last thing that Don Lemon did before
he did get fired let's uh watch a little
bit of this
the very policies that we implemented in
this country in the name of helping
black Americans have actually been
disastrous for black Americans and all
Americans and I think that that's
something that we need to wake up to in
1865 we were talking about the Black
Codes right that's right past enacted to
make it a crime for a black person to
carry a gun in the south
but you're equating that to the current
president you're referring to economic
chains what are you saying well I was
referring to Joe Biden's I think
ill-chosen expression to say they're the
party that wants to put you back into
chains what I'm actually saying is that
if you look at the policies of the
modern democratic party Democrats
absolutely so what I'm saying is that
actually it's policies like that of
Lyndon Johnson and Joe Biden that are
actually holding black women since the
war on poverty yes and in particular his
Great Society where he actually created
incentives in the family where if you're
a family you could actually get more
money by not having the father in the
home guess what you get you get what you
pay for I think it's been really bad for
the black community I think it's really
bad for all Americans what do you have
anything on this before I move on to
China I don't see what one has to do
with the other but go on I took up a lot
of time with Fox oh it's fine we have
time I don't really see what one has to
do with the other especially consider
and using the Civil War to talk about
Black Americans that war was not fought
for black people to have guns that's
that's that's not that war was fought
for black people to have freedoms in
this country yeah actually that's why
the Civil War was fought okay
for black people to have guns I think
actually you don't know funny fact is
black people did not get to enjoy the
other freedoms until their second
amendment rights were secured and I
think that that's one of the lessons
that we aren't allowed to enjoy the
freedoms I disagree with you on that Don
I disagree with you on it I think you're
doing a disservice to our country by
failing to recognize
and then you live in this country then
you can disagree with me but we're not
you mentioned it I disagree I think we
have to be able to talk about these
issues in the open regardless of the
color of our skin black Americans today
to say Okay so
Don Lemon is offended we can stop that
Don lemon's offended and uh you're not a
black American you can't say this people
are claiming that this is part of the
reason you got fired I don't buy that
for a second I mean since when
since when is the left-wing cable news
gonna fire one of their anchors for
playing the race card what is that
that's what's happening now at CNN
you're not allowed to play the race card
well then they have to fire everybody I
mean uh they did everyone's gone in that
case
so I don't really buy it
um
there's also this from the daily wire
saying it's less about playing race
cards and all that and more about
misogyny and sexism
daily wire posts uh article CNN insiders
took aim at former CNN anchor Don Lemon
after he was fired on Monday lemon was
unceremoniously sacked prompting him to
issue a statement in which he complained
at CNN's management did not have the
decency to tell me directly adding that
he was stunned
um and then uh
CNN disagreed with that and said that it
was uh that we did tell him and whatever
else who cares
uh one source told the Daily Mail Don
was given every indication when he made
the fake ass apology for his disgusting
comments and still no one wanted
anything to do with him uh this is after
I think the comments he's talking about
is when he uh made the he said about uh
Nikki Haley that she's Pastor Prime no
one owes him anything he should have had
the decency to not be a misogynistic
sexist POS Don truly believed he was
going to always get out of uh get a get
out of jail free card because he's black
and gay
which worked to his Advantage until it
couldn't
it doesn't matter what color you are or
what your sexuality is the source
continued he lost the respect of all the
women on staff and no one wanted to work
with him even after this he still acted
no differently and would give the women
he worked with attitude because he could
sense that they felt a certain way good
riddance and good luck getting a job
elsewhere
sources from CNN previously told the
Daily Mail that women upset at lemons
misogyny told management that either
lemon had to go or they would One Source
said people are hurt by his actions and
are not going to let this go it's like
every woman over 50 in America has taken
this as a personal insult the female
staffers at CNN definitely have
um he needs to make his vacation a
permanent one
lemon's various denigrations of women
have included suggesting to Bill Cosby's
sexual assault accuser Joan tarshish
tarshish that she could have she should
have bitten Cosby's penis
what uh intimating politician Nikki
Haley was Pastor Prime because she was
51 years old as he stated a woman is in
her prime in the 20s and 30s maybe 40s
and also asking panelists SE Cup whether
she was suffering from Mommy brain
so those are his those are his uh sexist
um
indiscretions apparently
you know that especially the last two
and we talked about this at the time the
thing when he said Nikki Haley's Pastor
Prime that's not it was it was
incoherent and it was stupid
but it it's it wasn't driven by his
hatred of women
uh saying this SC cup something about a
mommy brain you know that's like that's
an expression people use it's not it's
not sexist okay and even on the right we
shouldn't pretend because because we
we're happy that hey it's fine to be
happy that Don Lemon got fired but we
shouldn't jump on this bandwagon by
saying oh yeah I've talked about a mommy
brain well that's that's that's
unthinkable
that's sexist that's misogynistic oh
come on
um
no Don Lemon and this is not a defense
of him by the way at all
it's not that he's misogynistic he's not
he hates women
um
he's talking over women and he's
treating women she treats everybody that
way he's just an a-hole he's a jerk he's
a he's a narcissist like so many in the
business
that's what he is and he's also a
partisan untalented hack and he has been
for years that's why he deserves to get
fired
he doesn't even drive ratings should
have been fired a long time ago
on that basis alone
that's why it should have been fired
it's but it is it's there's some Poetic
Justice in the fact
that
though he has been a partisan untalented
untalented hack for years
uh and never got fired
um this is what takes him down when they
pin some bogus sexism charges on it
this is actually an example of the left
eating their own
and I and I think it's great
you know this is it is a it is a fitting
end to his career and I think for him
now this is not as we said this is not
the end of Tucker Carlson's career
because he's got a huge base of support
around him and whatever he does next
Millions people will go with him to that
next Endeavor we know that for Don Lemon
there's no one no one is sitting around
saying I gotta see what Don Lemon does
next
whatever Don Lemon goes I'm going with
him like there is for Don Lemon it's
difficult for anyone to start their own
media Empire uh Tucker Carlson could do
it be hard but he could do it Don Lemon
could never do that
okay he's not he can't start lemon news
or something and it's uh Don Lemon 24 7
people can go tune in
um
so
that doesn't exist for him this so and
therefore in his case this is
essentially the end of his career
especially because he got the misogyny
sexist label on the way out the door
it's also interesting to see and I you
know I don't know maybe we don't make
too much of this but as you know I'm I'm
someone who um studies
I'm kind of a student of the left's
victim hierarchy and this kind of
complicated equation that determines who
the Uber victim is and when you've got
competing victim claims how do you
decide who who triumphs in that
situation who the true victim is and on
the left victimhood is power so the
higher you are on the victimhood
hierarch it's kind of this in certainly
sort of like an inverse pyramid because
the higher you are on it it means the
more victimized you are but the more
victimized you are the more power you
have that's the way that it works on the
left
and
normally
in fact as this Source in CNN points out
I mean normally being black and gay that
gives you a lot of intersectional uh
victim power
and there's there's the only person who
could be above you on the hierarchy is
someone who's trans that's usually the
way it works and for a long time women
have been you know they're not as far
down as white men on the victim
hierarchy
um but they're pretty far down
so pretty much any victim claim that a
woman makes can be superseded by someone
who has more victim power than the woman
yet in this case
you have someone who's black and gay and
they're being taken out by victim claims
being made by women so that's uh that's
interesting
has there been an upheaval in the victim
hierarchy
are women climbing up the ladder once
more
I don't know
we'll have to uh
pay attention see what happens next hey
I'll do it for the show today talk to
you tomorrow have a great day Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]